(techno beats)
- Where's the car?
I parked it right here.
- I wanna be home
in bed grinding my teeth
- I'm so hungover
Suela, Consuela, Suela
- Oh yea oh
(snorting)
- Oh f-bleep.
- I made you favorite.
French toast
- Gracias Consuela
Did you cut the crusties off?
- Si, Amigo.
- Suela, we're going
down to Mexico.
Do you want us to say
anything to your family?
(snoring)
- We're just looking for
some scripts, vics, oxy
- TNN like pills, or
can we like ride the
schneef schnake as well?
- Why you have to
drive with you knees?
- I was taking a
bong hit, you idiot.
- No, no
- No policia.
Alcoholico.
Alcoholico!
- Okay!
- Can you take an animated GIF?
- Where I look like the
black dude who looks like
predator in Dave Matthews
Band, the violin player?
(thumping)
- I'm the Michael Jordan of
throwing Vicodin everywhere.
- I did half a
semester at Bard, so...
- Yeah.
- Don't f-bleep with me.
(hardcore techno)
- Why is our life so
f-bleep-ing hard, Wendy?
- Shut up!
(techno music)